the gift of life isn't the only thing
that survivors of infinity war will get
in the fourth avengers movie
according to leaked promo art for the
sequel that's emerged on the internet
they'll also be getting some slick new
suits at least it looks like thor and
rocket will
and just in time for halloween the
artwork in question looks to be the
backside of packaging for an avengers
related toy
and while the leaked photo isn't high
quality it does give fans an idea of
what a few marvel heroes might be
wearing in avengers 4.
ascended with red patches the suits are
a shiny silver white color
among the torso arms and sides of the
legs and black everywhere else
thor sports a thick black avengers a on
the chest plate of a suit
and wields what looks like an upgraded
version of his newest weapon the hammer
axe hybrid stormbreaker
and though rocket appears unarmed the
ingenious space rodent is probably still
pretty dangerous
what is that it's a bomb and you leave
it lying around i was gonna put it in a
box
taking a closer look at the photo you'll
notice that captain america also seems
to be wearing one of those new suits
to the left of the star spangled avenger
is the space-faring captain marvel
and she doesn't have a white suit
apparently instead she's seen wearing a
standard red navy and gold getup from
the comic books
which we previously got a glimpse of in
the trailer for the captain marvel movie
it makes sense that carol danvers will
be donning her signature suit
rather than getting the same outfit as
the rest of the avengers as she'll
probably be introduced in avengers 4
as a mysterious outsider known only to
nick fiore
it's sort of like in greece when sandy
wanted to join the pink ladies
she couldn't just show up and score one
of those sweet bubblegum pink jackets
she had to earn it
captain marvel might just have to do the
same thing thor rocket and cap
suits a vote the costume hank pym war
when he was leaping through the quantum
realm
in search of janet van dyne which makes
sense a popular avengers 4 fan theory
suggests that the heroes who didn't
dissolve into dust in infinity war
might use the quantum realm in their
quest to rescue all the people
thanos snapped away so what could all
this mean the text in the photo appears
to read the asgardian thor
wields the mighty stormbreaker in his
battle against his foes
rocket teams up with a new crew to guard
the galaxy against an even greater
threat
if this leak is legit then that new crew
line all but guarantees it that rocket
is joining the avengers
for this movie at least thor and captain
america might be rocket's closest
companions on the team
given that all three are shown wearing
the same silvery white costumes
one could theorize that the trio will
partner together on an adventure of
their own
specifically they might be slipping into
the new suits to travel through the
quantum realm
locating time vortexes skipping around
in the past
and stopping thanos from committing mass
genocide before he even gets a chance to
start
it would make sense for these three to
go on their own literal mini mission
much like the characters did in infinity
war that's kind of the only way to build
a story around a cast this big
avengers 4 co-directors joe and anthony
russo haven't confirmed much of anything
about the forthcoming superhero sequel
not even its title so we can't be
certain that these costumes are real
or if the movie will truly feature the
team using time travel to take down
thanos
it isn't uncommon for toy companies to
create alternate costumes that
characters never wear in films
a toy for infinity war showed hulk
bursting out of the hulkbuster suit
and that never happened in the movie so
maybe these suits are only for avengers
4 action figures
and not avengers 4 actors and all the
ideas about the film utilizing the
quantum realm
well they're pretty compelling theories
but until the filmmakers confirm them
they're just theories sourceless leaks
had unconfirmed speculation aside
it's clear that the pieces of the
avengers 4 puzzle are slowly but surely
starting to come together
especially now that the movie has
wrapped filming as avengers 4 inches
closer to its may 3rd 2019 launch date
and starter's official marketing
campaign we should get a better idea of
what's legitimate and what's just
another product of the ever-moving rumor
mill